[Musique]
et pour commencer deux informations qui
viennent d'être annoncées par le premier
ministre jean castex à partir de demain
le port du masque en extérieur ne sera
plus obligatoire sauf dans certaines
circonstances comme les regroupements
les lieux bourdais ou encore les stades
et à partir de dimanche levée du couvre
feu
ces décisions ont été prises au vu de
l'amélioration de la situation sanitaire
plus rapide que prévu aujourd'hui ma
quatrième vague elle va arriver c'est à
dire que le hockey
vu comment on s'oriente là on aura une
circulation du virus à l'automne on n'a
pas tant cette immunité collective et on
n'est pas prêt de l'atteindre
même avec les 40 millions qui est
l'objectif qui a été avancé par jean
pierre au texte du coup on a leur
circulation virale donc pour l'instant
ce n'est pas une hypothèse on n'a pas
rencontré pas encore inscrit dans un
scénario où il n'y a pas de vague à
l'automne
comment nettoyer efficacement sa voiture
pour se protéger du coran d'un virus est
une question pour victoire attention
victoire ben alors à la peine dans le
mime le même voiture à nîmes le même
voiture victoire bayonnaise pas bon on a
l'impression qu'une vache mais elle
n'était pas là elle n'était pas là nous
allons jouer
vous allez jouer avec les expressions g
vous citer une liste d je vais vous
citer je vous y réside pas là ma place
je vous propose maintenant de jouer à
exister inventé un mot sur cristiano
ronaldo en quelques secondes il a fait
perdre 4 milliards de dollars à coca
cola lors d'une conférence de presse
l'attaquant portugais a en effet écarté
les bouteilles de soda devant lui a
préféré se tourner vers une bouteille
d'eau et ce geste à lui seul a fait
chuter les actions coca cola en bourse
ont regardé cette semaine
[Musique]
c'est tout à fait l'esprit de certains
c'est à dire qu'ils ne se rendent pas
compte qu'il est en train d'enlever son
sponsor est en fait il enlève ce qu'ils
payent quand on connaît le poids des
sponsors et des marques dans le foot on
peut dire que ce jerricans en arène est
en réalité on est courageux en tout cas
un geste très fort on vous rappelle
qu'une canette de 33 centilitres
contient l'équivalent de sept morceaux
de sucre et que les boissons sucrées
favorise l'obésité les maladies telles
que le dire donc comme on a le dos il
est plus sage de s'en passer mon genou
face rappelle pas des faits le groupe va
quand même
d'autant qu'en cette période de forte
chaleur il faut savoir cette boisson n'a
pas de pouvoir désaltérant
donc il va falloir boire alors quand on
boira tension de l'eau on peut en
trouver partout il ya que deux dans tous
les aliments gars de l'eau il ya que
deux aliments dans lesquelles il n'y a
pas d'eau le sucre et l'huile
sinon il ya de l'eau partout alors on
peut consommer des pastèques et des
agrumes et des concombres d'ailleurs
fait un petit peu tout juste franchi
alors la question que tout le monde se
pose
il faut boire frais où il faut boire
chaud c'est vrai faut pas trop en tout
cas pas trop froid rosé c'est mieux
frais alors oui attention je n'ai envie
loi ferait on a envie 10h06 aussi il ne
faut pas consommer de boissons durée tic
comme le café et de boissons qui
déshydrate comme le rosé comme diane le
dira gérard je ne bois pas et je me
rends plus et pour danser il faut que je
sois sous donc je ne vais pas penser
avec m
[Applaudissements]
c'est un tout petit bon moi qui dirige
un petit peu une habitude ça se change
regardez maintenant c'est moi c'est pas
que les canaux désolé mais après vous
repérez arrêté on va par caraux je suis
énormément déçu sur le dessert parce que
dès le départ
tu nous a présenté des trucs vraiment
rome le reste au mans vichy
alors pour votre gouverne c'est michelin
sans rien vous pouvez continuer c'est
gros c'est mal présentés c'est vraiment
laissé aller manger mais pas du tout
c'est de trop mais c'était pas affiné
c'est pas mal alors viens tu as sauvé
les liners oui c'est ça attention de
l'eye liner je suis tombé dans le
panneau mais tu t'en sers aussi pour un
rouge à lèvres la lnr on le met pour les
sourcils on le met donc au dessus ici on
un en chine
vous savez que le marché de la chirurgie
esthétique à la plus forte croissance au
monde et l'opération à la mode consiste
à se faire agrandir les oreilles à la
façon d'un lutin afin de s'amincir le
visage on lit dans la presse chinoise et
témoignages de jeunes gens ravis de leur
nouvelle oreille c'est magique je n'ai
rien changé à mon visage et pourtant
tous mes amis m'ont dit que j'avais
l'air différent depuis que je les fais
et là je la vole déguisés mais en même
de ton pigeons à ces faits dans la crise
comment 18 titres l'équipe
alors on se pince on se dit mais de quoi
il parle de 2018 de la dernière coupe du
monde et de la formidable victoire de
l'équipe de france ou de la guerre 14-18
contre l'allemagne sans doute évidemment
soit excitant ça laisse une petite
ambiguïté évidente est savamment avec
toi même très belle est bien sûr le on
est nickel fer 5 sur le banc je sais pas
c'était les téléspectateurs peuvent voir
on est on est en bas je veux dire on est
c'est non mais c'est super mais c'est
bien après le ceo quiconque vous êtes
heure là mais c'est l'intérieur c'est
l'intérieur jusqu'au fait référence là
en l'occurrence à la première guerre
mondiale ça nous ramène à la fameuse
phrase d'orwell en 45 qui disait que le
football cité comme la guerre mais sans
les fusils bah là on est en plein dedans
mais et libérant le volet je découvre ce
petit orifice qui permettait un tireur
de surveiller la rue de rivoli à quoi
pensez-vous et donc ça ce qu'elle voit
ok ça c'est fait et nos deux invités
étaient extrêmement intéressé par tous
les orifices secrets de la marine je
suis sûr qu'on vous a convaincu héloïse
balances ton secret hashtag alan je suis
très intéressé s'est consacré moi je
sais de quoi s'agit mais je suis fan de
céline dion pour que tu m'aimes encore
ou qui suivent mon coeur oui bah oui
même s'il emporte ailleurs sinon ce
moment gênant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]